good morning believe nation today's
message is go for it over to you rich
device starting at the bottom on emily
is wherever you are today everybody
starts at the bottom and there is no
advantage to starting ten years ago as a
boat starting today in fact it's better
today than it was that our products are
better our line is better our plan is
better as more proving it's a better
plan today than when we started
and sometimes there are no answers as to
whether you want to be in business or
would like to be in business you you
just got to put your toe in the water
you know if you're going to wait till
you know everything you'll never do
anything and you always say well I got
check some more I'm in doing more
research so go ahead just keep going and
you'll never get in a business you going
to go swimming and go to get wet you
know and then you find the people who've
got a hot button for having a business
of their own and want to do their own
thing and like the chance to build a big
business well you got to have that dream
that's why the people talk about having
a dream all you got to have a little bit
of a dream and then you see I'll go and
get customers it you know I get a big
chance to build a really a big thing I'm
about gets customers when you start
something new it's not easy but life is
easier when you got a business here
you're making some money makes a little
easier so stick with it find our way
through it just find out an answer
it works folks this business works for
those who work it there comes a point in
time in your life where you just need to
decide you're going to go for it in a
lot of things in life not just in a
start in the business in action that guy
or girl out in deciding to get married
or not in saying yes to that opportunity
or not at some point you have to decide
to go for it and it's hard because you
want to have perfect information right
you want to have it all figured out you
will never have perfect information by
the time you get perfect information you
will have missed
your opportunity and so if you want to
have success as an entrepreneur you need
to jump in before you have the complete
picture and you adjust and you figure
things out as you go I lost a 40 million
dollar deal in my first business because
I was too late because I was planning
and planning and planning and planning
and not doing enough I still ended up
selling my company but I didn't get to
40 million dollars that the other guy
got and I don't want that to happen to
you and it already is happening to you
that's the frustration that's the
problem you will have already had genius
level ideas that other people are making
money off of because you were tinkering
and thinking and strategizing and
planning day after day after day and not
actually doing anything this person went
out there and made tons of money and had
a huge impact off of your idea what
can't that be you and don't complain
it's not because you didn't have
resources it's not because of whatever
reason you're telling yourself it's good
you didn't take action you got to go and
do it and you don't need to go all-in
you don't need to burn the boats you
don't need to take out a huge mortgage
on your house or a massive loan that
puts you way back you can start smaller
but start doing something as soon as you
get an idea for something that you want
to test that might be something big that
you might have this big passion for then
try immediately today right now take
some small action towards moving that
ball forward and figure out do I want to
keep doing this with others and they can
come alive my passion about this is
there a path to adding value for people
or not a lot of the things that you have
when you're head once you start actually
doing it you don't like it and you quit
that's great we move on to something
else but you can't actually get to the
finish line you can't have that big
impact you can't be the person that you
know you can be until you actually go
for something let's do it today believe
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious what have you been holding back
on what's the thing that you haven't
gone for you it that you want to that
you've been holding yourself back on and
hopefully by writing it down in the
comments below it will force you to
actually do something
today make a powerful decision write it
down I'm going to join in the discussion
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Jody Holland Jody thank you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really means a
lot to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events better
hey believe nation for those of you who
want a little more motivation insight
expertise on going for it
here are some bonus clips that I hope
you'll enjoy I believe desire and will
to win is everything I don't know why
I'm like I am but my butt's always
burning
there's always something say art
dadgummit you're supposed to go far
alright dad gummit you're supposed to be
somebody you're supposed to make a
difference with your lie what does the
$500,000 your person do the $50,000 your
person doesn't do you looking outside
and study those two individuals
everything seems to be the same they
both are the same sex they both are the
same age have the same training the same
positions the same contract the same
fringe benefits
they both are successful they work hard
they're good family people make tough
commitments but what's the difference
what does the $500,000 your person do
the $50,000 your person doesn't do he
pays the price and a little bit more he
works Harding a little bit more he's
loyal to the company a little bit more
he believes in a little bit more he
makes Maine a little bit more he saves
money a little bit more if you want to
win in these United States you got to be
tough and you can't quit the last thing
I'll talk to you about today and
building this winning edge is folks if
you want to win in business you got to
be a leader leadership is everything you
show me anything in these United States
that win I'll show you a leader at work
you show me a successful church Boy
Scout Troop club football team business
I'll show you some a run by leader see
see I thought at one time in my life you
had to be smart to win I used to have
these smart people that dress so pretty
and talk so pretty and use these big
word
they just intimidated me I said aren't
you can't ever be that good why don't
you just throw in the towel and going
back coach football for living and I
found two things out about smart people
I think it's almost impossible for a
smart person to win in Fitness in
America today because I find smart
people spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out they always try to
figure out an easier way in a quicker
way and another thing I found out about
smart people they just don't get around
to doing nothing they see somebody like
art Williams everybody said well he
can't do it and somebody like that can't
do it but he does it see folks I want
you to know almost everybody in America
almost does enough to win they almost
get there they almost over the hump they
almost have it going they almost in
everything they do almost as a way of
life almost everybody in America but the
winners do it what do they do they do
whatever it takes to get the job done
they do it and do it and do it and do it
and do it until the job gets done and
then they talk about how great it is to
be somebody they're proud of we need
leaders in America who can do it if you
want to become somebody do it if you
want to go and finish for yourself do it
if you want to become financially
independent do it I hear too much talk
in these United States everybody can
talk a good game we need people in
America who can do it I go all over this
country with a always and I have people
say are you you count on me wonderful
just do it hard I can't t this is my
light last stop I'm gonna win now super
duper just do it alright if I could just
have one good month and get the ball
going I know I could make it big super
just do it hard if I could just pay off
this debt I could really go great just
do it my heart if I could just sell my
house do it alright but how do they
selling do it anyway
hard I'm not making any money what can I
do
did you just do it I do what are you do
it and do it and do it hard I guess you
have a win this contest
super duper just do it alright I'm over
the hunt now watch my smoke grave just
do it
hard I wanna make it so bad I'm tasting
what I do you just do it alright I'm a
vice president now can I quit doing it
know my heart I don't know if I can keep
on keepin on I'm really hurting what I
do you just do it do what are you do it
and do it and do it alright all my life
I want to be somebody important well
what do it then
alright I'm gonna save money so I don't
have to go through this again great just
do it I don't feel like I've had enough
training what'd I do you just do it
how are my manners you don't give me no
help what I do you just do it all right
you don't understand I was mr.
everything in my former company you
don't mean I have to start off down at
the bottom and do it do you if you
really got to do it hard
art what's the primary difference
between winners and losers so when it
the winners do it they do it and do it
and do it and do it until the job gets
done and then they talk about how great
it is to finally have achieved something
you need and I'm glad they are that they
didn't quit like everybody else and how
wonderful it is to finally be somebody
they're proud of and make a difference
with their life kind of cliches but just
do it a lot of time and spent
about something oh yeah talking about it
you know but when you actually get
something down either on paper or in
code or you know in front of someone
that's when things start happening and
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
the important thing is that you make
decisions and you keep moving course but
you have to get it out there and you
have to start and you have to be brave
enough to take the criticism I always go
back to the punk movement from the 70mm
people get out and be on the street if
you are a teenager back then yeah
anything well and they say oh it's there
would be a it would be learning in front
of people it like they get out on the
street and the first time with a guitar
yeah you know they're learning how to
play and they're getting better and
better and better
yeah and I think it's really important
to get it down do it
you can't it edit at it it's one thing
to philosophize about training
strategies and to you know compare this
philosophy versus another
argue about you know how many grams
versus how many grams is is but then
there's something to be said for doing
the damn thing you know just just do it
you know
stop talking stop trying to sound
slightly you meet these people that want
to engage in these conversations and
one-up the professional body both ah you
know more about neutering them as it is
I mean I'm not straight I'm not where
I'm at because because I know more about
nutrition than everybody else on the
planet you know in fact I dare say that
the the top bodybuilding athletes that
are on stage are not the man on stage
[ __ ] right here because they know more
about training science and nutrition
then the the average person sitting in
the audience a lot of times is different
between the person in the audience and
the person that on stage doing it is the
use of the knowledge